hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
it is treatise on virtues and vices
alkawin of york is going to use the
schema long established by that time of
the eight capital vices the major kinds
of
problematic character traits that lead
us into doing all sorts of other bad
things
and this is coming from john cassian and
avagrius ponticus and among the ones
that are
identified in there there's three that
you could look at as particularly
connected with our emotions and problems
that arise from them as opposed to mere
drives or desires
or
a lot of things that involve comparison
between ourselves and others and those
three
would be what what get called anger or
era that's a general latin term for
being angry
weariness or acadia weariness is not a
complete translation of it but actually
there isn't a great translation of it as
we'll talk about in a bit even from
going from greek where the acadia comes
about to latin and then sorrow or
sadness tristitia
and each of these
can be very problematic i think
everybody understands that anger itself
can be
intrinsically bad in many cases and even
when we think that it's helping us do
good we're often doing bad but maybe not
with these these other two and he
devotes considerably more discussion to
anger each of these is discussed in a
chapter
in this sequential listing of the
capital vices 31
32 and 33 but there is also an earlier
chapter
chapter 24 about proneness to anger and
that's relevant as well so what does he
tell us about anger
the very first sentence could lead us if
we're not paying close attention to
think well you know anger's not really
that bad unless reason is not in charge
of it because he says anger is one of
the eight principle vices which
if it's not ruled by reason
is turned into fury so we've got two
different words there two different
anger language things ira this basic
human emotion and then fury or wrath
right a more intense kind of anger that
is clearly uh you know being mastered by
uh you know its impulses an overruling
reason he goes on and says
such that a person will be powerless in
his soul doing what is not appropriate
what is not fit what they shouldn't do
right
now is he saying well some anger's okay
and you know it's just if you go too far
and aren't listening to reason
yes and no it's not quite so simple
as this he says if it sits down in the
heart
meaning anger it banishes foresight from
it so
providencia is is foresight and what we
can talk about here
is that anger has a general tendency and
particularly once it extends into wrath
in interfering with our rational or our
cognitive faculties that should be
guiding it so the very fact that we're
getting angry tends to
you know seduce our practical
rationality so it banishes foresight
from our heart nor will the heart be
able to seek after judgment judicia of
right discretion
or have the strength of honest
contemplation it's interfering with our
ability to think about things or
maturity of counsel we don't listen to
other people who are giving us good
advice
but it seems to do all things
through a certain headlong falling now
that's a wonderful
translation
here it does things through this
headlong falling
you know a certain kind of
you know tripping and falling or or you
know losing control you think about when
you're running and you're running too
fast and you can't actually control
your direction right
that's a nice metaphor for what it's
like to
get angry and lose control and you know
he talks about this in that chapter on
proneness to anger
what does anger actually do
anger without measure is without reason
and he goes on he's quotes a number of
scripture passages that are that are uh
relevant to this he says anger does not
have mercy nor does fury breaking out
noah limit to vengeance
now that's interesting because there
he's saying not just okay fury or wrath
problematic anger maybe not so
problematic anger itself does not know
mercy or misericordia something that's
very important to have
you know anger is bad
because it disturbs the mind so it
squanders correct counsel you know and
so it goes on from there now he does
actually in that chapter say that some
anger can be just and necessary so this
might lead somebody say well yeah when
somebody wrongs you and you've got to
stand up for yourself
not at all what al kuhn is saying
notice too that he is addressing
a reader count guy who is a military man
right so
he's saying the only anger that's
actually just necessary is that which
you have against your own
sins your own
faults the things that are going wrong
with you he says it's just necessary
when a person is angered against his own
sins and is indignant against himself
when he does wrongly
so you know
this this uh makes a lot of sense he
also gives some advice about what do you
do when other people get angry you know
try to have gentleness with them kind
words
you can try to reason with them you
might be successful you might not be
successful
so that's that's anger we'll come back
to that in just a
moment what about this other thing
acadia
translated here is weariness but it's
not just weariness it can also be
a kind of distractedness a kind of
energetic you know seeking around for
things but never settling down on what
you're supposed to do so he says that
this is a disease which tries to greatly
harm those serving god and he talks
about a couple different sides to this
so there's the idol there's an idleness
an inactive side to it and he's got this
great phrase in latin otiosis homo
torpescot right so the the inactive
you could also say the lazy or the
um
you know free from
from work the idol person
torpescot is in a torpor meaning they
it's not just that they're inactive
they they're just kind of laying around
they're just kind of doing
nothing
or they're frittering away their time
and there's
a side to it of a lack of positive
interest or desire or joy so he goes on
and he says
this person becomes inactive in carnal
desires now that's interesting to note
too right what are carnal desires you
know eating drinking exercise having sex
those sorts of things the person
stops being interested in these these
sorts of matters they stop having desire
for them they also don't delight in
spiritual work they don't enjoy
like reading or thinking
they don't rejoice in the salvation of
their soul nor grows cheerful in the
assistance of fraternal labor doing
things with other people
they don't enjoy that so that's one side
of it the other side they do actually
have desires and he says they covet and
desire concupiscat at desiraz right uh
tantum such that or so much that the
idle mind runs through
all things prime example of this that al
quinn of course wouldn't know but we
could easily do
what we call doom scrolling right
scrolling through say social media and
you know just looking at stuff and maybe
thinking about it a little bit and then
moving on to the next thing
in the old days when we had a cable tv
and there was the sawing something like
450 channels and nothing on people would
sit there with the remote and just click
through the channels that's an example
of this letting your mind range over
everything reading books but without
actually reading them
you know just sort of scanning through
them
[Music]
we could think about you know all sorts
of other stuff people on tinder swiping
swiping swiping swiping swiping some
people get on tinder not because they're
looking to hook up with somebody but
just for entertainment's sake that could
be an expression of this moving from
activity to activity to activity
so this is a an interesting emotional
problem that arises and it leads to all
sorts of other problems then we have
sorrow or tristiti or sadness is another
way to translate it
and he tells us that there's two kinds
of sorrow
one of them is actually not a vice one
of them is actually quite helpful for us
he says that it's healing healing sorrow
is when the mind of the sinner is made
sad from their sins and made so sad that
they seek to do confession and
repentance and desires to be converted
to god things that al kuwain was talking
about earlier in the treaties if you're
sad about being a screw-up or because of
the bad things that you did wrong
doesn't even necessarily need to be in a
theological context like alcohol and
places it in here you could say wow i
don't like the kind of person that i am
i feel bad about that i need to change
this if it leads to positive action then
it's not bad sorrow
what is bad sorrow
he says the sadness of this world is
different
it works the death of the soul
it's not able to profit anything in good
work it perturbs the mind and often
sends it into desperation and takes away
hope of future good things so it doesn't
lead to any changes it's just a dwelling
on how crappy you are or the bad actions
that you engaged in or pick whatever
else you want to
substitute in there and this is a
problematic disposition according to
you know this entire tradition running
from the vagras and cassian all the way
up to alcuin several decades later
now each of these is problematic because
it produces other vices and sins so
let's look at at sorrow first he says
that
from this is born
malice you know delighting and doing bad
things rancor people who are sad often
are rancorous they're irritable right
timidity of spirit
unwillingness to take risks bitterness
despair
often even no delight
of the present life
so you know bitterness and despair those
are very problematic it could be that
you don't even enjoy
doing the things here outside of any
sort of christian theological framework
and that that can be a serious issue
what about the um weariness what does
weariness lead to he says
when it besieges the person's mind it
infects it with many miseries and these
teach many evils what are they
sleepiness laziness of good works okay
so this ties in with something i should
point out that in the seven deadly sins
you're not going to find weariness or
sorrow because both of them are rolled
into
one of the sins
sloth right and this is an aspect
of it so you know
sleepiness laziness of good works
instability of place now remember that
this is a monastic author so he's a monk
stability of place is something very
important for monks particularly for the
benedictines staying in one place
wandering about from place to place
stupidity in working not actually
persevering in your working laziness
you know
good works um weariness of heart
murmuring
and vain talking it leads to
talking talking smack we could say right
in our contemporary parlance so that's
another big problem what about anger
what does anger lead us to so all sorts
of of issues right he says
here we go
anger can lead us to um
[Music]
ferment of mind right having our
constantly thinking about stuff quarrels
that's a no brainer right when we're
irritate irritable and irritated we get
into quarrels
violence
clamor you know saying all sorts of
things about other people that a-hole
right
indignation audacity anger makes us
daring to do things that we shouldn't do
right
blasphemies shedding of blood
homicide
desire of vengeance remembrance of
injuries and you know back in the
chapter on pronunce of anger he talks
about you know uh other things that that
are like this and he and he says you
know if if um
you think about your your own anger
right and compare it to that of other
people you don't like it when they get
that way think about your own self and
how stupid you become when you're angry
he says you know if you're angry against
another person then there's two evils
right the foolish person who got angry
and the fool who you've become who's
getting angry and he says
wouldn't it be better for you to be good
even though that person's bad why will
you be made bad from the wickedness of
another so another part of anger is sort
of like losing perspective right we
could say
and each of these has remedies now
interestingly let's work our way
backward from
anger the remedies for anger are indeed
virtues like patience and you know
long-sufferingness but they're also
cognitive
we can you know
recall scripture verses like he does
here you know
he says
don't be conquered by evil but conquer
evil and good um
uh
an erasable man provokes quarrels
um you know
be angry but don't sin that's one thing
that you can do
the other thing is you can remind
yourself about what it is that anger
itself does and how counterproductive it
would be
to allow yourself to give into it
what about weariness how do we deal with
that so he says this is conquered
through
zeal of reading zeal of reading is
something that he treats in chapter 5
reading scripture
zeal means like constant desire and
application for it so that helps with
with weariness
um a si a suitedity or perseverance of
good works
um
through the desire of prophets of future
blessedness a confession of temptation
right when you when you're actually
feeling that way you like say what how
things actually are right and maybe to
yourself maybe to another stability of
place
not you know getting outside of as we
say your lane right not buying into the
grass is greener on the other side sort
of thing that leads people into this
this you know acadia type of behavior
and then he says the instant exercise of
whatever kind of art and labor or
prayers and vigils so that you're never
found idle actually doing things and
sticking with them is how you conquer
acadia
what about sadness how do you deal with
the the sadness of
the world
he says that um it's conquered by
spiritual joy
so
you know it's difficult to make yourself
joyful when you're already sad but it is
it is possible and joy as opposed to
sorrow hope of future things consolation
of the scriptures or fraternal
conversation and spiritual enjoyment you
know
removing the condition of isolation of
being stuck in
yourself and engaging with others
perhaps through reading perhaps through
conversations or things like that so
each of these
has its remedies that alcohol wants to
help the readers out with these are all
some important
capital vices that he thinks we need to
watch out for
you